duty yep what are we gonna do right now
whose presents
my pleasure your presents that you
bought for yourself or that you bought
for other people
for myself you didn't buy them for
yourself you bought them for other
people
but i have a car i have a new car what
do you mean show it to me it's around
next to dunkin donuts cars
oh right
i don't know
well we have to wrap it up okay so i
don't know if you guys saw but a few
weeks back a few weeks maybe last week
two weeks i don't know anymore time is
this doesn't exist in this house um
but we went christmas shopping and i
took tech at 1999 center and he picked
out a bunch of presents for all of his
friends and family and today we're going
to wrap them
i'll go get the presents let's go get
the presents dude
okay
monkey judy yes what did we just do i
use
i just make i
brought up the present yeah okay
so we got all of the presents that tycho
bought where you put them on the table
so that we know what we got we're gonna
review
who's getting what
we have our wrapping station
we have the bows
uh
string yarn
little baggies
more baggies ornaments just different
things to make the present look nice
he is gonna give his classmates or jiu
jitsu classmates a bunch of um little
baggies with like treats in them and
stuff so we have this station kind of
going
oh my god you scared the crap out of me
what he's gonna do that's really what
he's gonna do that's cute are those
candy canes yeah full of candy yeah what
the hell you've never seen them
i
too bad
my childhood was amazing it was so
i'm just kidding but okay so this is
this is the christmas station you ready
duty
who's that for
nice and i like how you just put your
mouth on it
you're sick right now so i can't wait
for grandpa to get your germs stop
keeps putting it in his mouth he doesn't
have covet
if you were wondering we got him tested
he just has a flu and then he passed it
on to me now i have a flu where the how
did papa go he was just coming down the
stairs
too many things going on i get it i'm
sorry
how in the world does this thing work
you can't say that you're old man
you just call me a little man he called
you an old man
dude chill out i got feelings too buddy
oh
buddy
buddy my buddy
[Applause]
[Applause]
what is that oh it's a paper cutter yeah
wow that thing works pretty good that's
pretty good
[Applause]
do what no cutting it no way jose
okay
of course of course wait let me let me
teach you you've never rest before
okay i'll tell you what to do with the
tape okay you ready leave it like that
don't put it anywhere
okay
i need hold on hold on hold on
okay
ready duty
tape right here
oh no
okay well we want to get half of the
tape on the box and the other tape
on
put it just on the paper
okay one more you're gonna put the tape
this way okay
you want a little bit of tape
i'll show you how go slow put a little
bit of tape on the paper and a little
bit on the box
yeah like that you see
so now it's stuck
you got it
here's another one i'll tell you one
[Applause]
wait up wait up wait up
[Applause]
cool you got
it oh yeah i'll help you do the next one
half and half
there you go yep
perfect
[Applause]
oh you did it okay wait i'll tell you
where to put it
i'm not ready for you yet you're too
fast
that's all i need
okay right here half and half oh you put
it on the paper i need another one
i need another one right here like i
want it maybe this big
careful okay cause i could cut you like
that
there you go
all of this
yep right there press it down
good job can i do it myself
hey monkey can you tell me who each of
these presents are for oh god you forgot
are you serious okay who who'd you get
this for
this big barbie you don't know what
about this one about this gardening hose
who did you get that for
the gardening is for your cousin
no who's that for
for grandma oh it's thoughtful
what about this screwdriver set who'd
you get that for
[Music]
your uncle just to fix something
what about what about this uh remote
control car what'd you get that for
me for you
no you can't give presents for yourself
i gotta give to other people who is that
for
for me
what about this one there's another
remote control car who's that for
what about derek's brother doesn't he
get something
i don't know
no
i'm i'm pretty sure you probably got
these two since they're twins so you
probably got them
you can have a scooter
what scooter did you buy a scooter i
don't see no scooter here
you bought a a scooter from one of his
cousins
a scooter
a scooter
what
who did you buy this dinosaur for monkey
you don't know
by the way
taika went with mama to i believe either
dollar tree 99 cent store to pick out
gifts so that's why it's so cuny because
that's something we do every year where
a geo goes to the store and asks taika
to pick out all these gifts for people
and it's just cool that now
before he would get like a random bag of
rubber bands
or like a random flashlight but now this
the toys and presents are starting to
make sense because he's older
and he's uh
actually has a thought process now
what okay let me see this will write in
chinese
no i'm not okay let me do it though the
way you like to do it
t
that's called lowercase monkey he yeah
but i don't know he does a different way
oh
okay all the blockers
hey is that how you write your name
yeah
yeah stop stop stop you gotta sign it
duty here say it
he's gonna write on that little thing i
know i just realized
hey that's pretty good tea but it's all
the way backwards
he's gonna write the other way is gonna
write a mirror style
okay that's hieroglyphics
let him do it
what
did you forget you were once poor
nope i was born a genius
did you know we did that wait who's that
one for grandpa ground let me take off
that's awesome
why'd you get that for grandpa monkey
how come you got it for grandpa okay
grandpa i don't know how to turn this
off
you're just gonna have to wrap it that
way hopefully it stays on
this way
they're gonna start
just wait for it to stop okay maybe it
stops on its own good call how come you
got this for grandpa monkey yeah how
come you bought it for grandpa cause i
love you
but why because how do you know
grandpa's gonna like it i don't know you
don't know it just made you think of
grandpa mm-hmm oh okay
i don't know
okay so time to check in we're gonna
pause for tonight because we're gonna go
where are we gonna go what are we gonna
go look at right now
christmas lights
i wanna keep the cat today hey come here
tell tell everybody about what you
wrapped already show them your presents
come here nice
whoa wow what came out of there
looking out of there unicorn poop oh
yeah okay what did you what
tell me about your presents
yeah
cover your mouth dude
wow these look so good write your name
wow
look at that so we did one two three
four we did five presents so far good
job
one
two
three yep
good job duty
all right good job let's go look at some
christmas lights
zero zebras you will want too okay
and we have arrived look at this
so cool
okay another thing is that side where
there's so many cars
is supposedly the fast pass i think
everyone feels duped outside because
we're just general they're not empty
sorry guys you've been duped
back there look duty
wow
wow
whoa look at that big christmas track
hold on
so it looks like i spoke too soon
because we're
the losers now joke's on you i know i
talk too much
but i'm not mad because taika here is
entertaining me with some really awesome
magic you want to show yeah okay
go for it dude
wait wait wait wait wait wait we gotta
do another one let me let me get it
because i have light in there there we
go ready go do it
right here
spit it out
that's awesome good job dude i would
hide it and i would disappear okay now
let me see
no
hey there it is good job good job
so we are making progress it's a really
cool setup they have different tents
and every tent you can pick up like hot
cocoa kettle corn and they have other
snacks they have a concession stand or a
hot cider
and it's so cool because you don't even
enter but now you can already get snacks
or maybe they made these longs these
lines long on purpose so that you get
hungry you said you wanted kettle corn
oh yeah baby is that that like caramel
kind of idea
well not the caramel kind chocolate
cover i don't know it's just sweet corn
it's just sugar
that's it
we got the kettle corn and the hot cocoa
this is on the kettle of popcorn oh it's
called kettle corn because it's sweet
they make it with sugar
do that it's delicious you crazy
monkey
i don't like it i like popcorn at home
and the peanut and the peanut butter and
the popcorn you want to throw it away
give it to me you don't want it i do oh
okay let's test it
hey duty
we're about to enter and look at all the
lights
are you excited dude
look at that house yeah it's santa's
house
yeah finally
what are we going to get out of our car
yeah
hey you just farted on me
stop that's so gross
okay look
[Music]
the glittering lights
[Music]
baby
[Music]
here's a suit from tyka's point of view
wow
so this is at the las vegas speedway so
this is where
uh they do all the like the car what is
it called not drag racing car drag
racing car racing yeah like any type of
races like that they hold it here so
right now i think we're in the garage
i actually think we're under the
bleachers
but isn't that where they go where they
parked their cars really no am i
tripping no i think it's under the
bleachers
oh yeah what the what the what was i
thinking
about you gonna
fall
we
wish you a merry
christmas
okay
look at the big mask look at that
excuse me
no it's not it's
no it's not no it's a pirate no it says
oopsie right there it does say oopsie is
look at these cool trees oh look at that
roller coaster
look at that so cool
look at that
that love love welcome to las vegas sign
that's iconic
oh
hey it's elvis duty that's not a person
that's elvis baby
one two three o'clock little baba
what a guitar
i don't know anything yeah he plays
las vegas
viva
las vegas look at that this is vegas
strong oh the ferris wheel yeah
but that's not first wheel
oh
that's so big ghetto not to be confused
with ghetto i know it's spelled funny
but it's ghetto
we are entering
the neon forests
are you kidding me no i'm not kidding
i'm pretty serious
that's stuck i want a purple light tree
in my house
can we get a purple light tree yeah
that's pretty nice
it's very nice
look at it it is so
pretty
you can't nope you can get it
bye bye
all right what is what's happening what
is that
what is it a mermaid what's going on no
no that's santa i know but what is
are they spilling wine or what is it
going on over there oh these are that's
reindeer oh look at this pink one they
got a pink one yeah these are all green
i love it these are right there
is really pretty
feliz navidad
hey
these are reindeers oh they are
reindeers good job feliz navidad
look it's a 12 days of christmas song a
a partridge and a pear tree
two turtle doves three french and
whatever whatever whatever and a
pineapple and a pear tree
ah
look at that and then
six tabatapa seven tapatapa
papa
you get what i'm talking about right
okay we are home now and that was a four
hour excursion
like
what
we waited in that line to get in for
like three hours and honestly it was not
worth it
i'm sorry it just was not worth it the
lights
they were cute
but not for three hours long cute
they're probably like a good 20 minutes
wait in line for 20 minutes cute you
know what i mean anything past 20
minutes you're like nah this ain't worth
it but you couldn't leave because you're
just stuck
cars on cars no no no don't play any
music right now
um
you need to go to bed it's already ten
your bedtime is nine
let's go say good night
good night good night cha cha yep